we're here again remotely by the magic
of video teleconferencing and you've had
to do some upgrading I understand I've
been wanting people to ask me about my
upgrading hell it's something where I
guess all of our audience can find
common cause you may not be running the
same mix of kits as I am but ones
attitude towards upgrading I think
divisors into two camps are you were
serious early adopter of anything that's
new or are you like me token dinosaur
it's only six years old what do you mean
I should be upgrading it I have two pcs
that run Windows 10 I have two iPads and
the one letter is the center of all my
efforts is the legacy unit really in
steps going all the way back to the
1970s but at the moment it's a Linux box
right and the Linux box I have at the
moment but I'm in the process of
changing it Sean it's only six years old
as my dad used to say that's a dad get
with it son these things should last a
lifetime and I always say that to Steven
Lee he looks to heaven whenever I say it
and I think you do too a bit but you
know let's be honest computers tablets
whatever are becoming a household
appliance yeah and it certainly used to
be that you would buy a household
appliance and expect it to last 10 years
or maybe if you bought amelie 20 years
yes
quite so that's exactly right but as we
all know is just not like that
we and you've got to be flexible enough
to to know exactly when it's the right
time to upgrade for you when I'm in as
it were Windows desktop mode I'm happy
to live with the Windows 10 and that the
people at work keep it up to date and
all
for me and it's not the main focus of
what to use but they're there when I
need them this time thinking back what
was the earliest UNIX box I heard it was
in the early 1990s his mic report UNIX
it was in those days running on very
underpowered PC 386 486 sort of chips
something like that and it was okay it
was a home UNIX system it was with a
sense of were wonderful boding really
when I had to move away from UNIX that
they were so familiar with for 20 years
to actually having to embrace Linux and
in those early days and one of my
procedures is the legendary John masters
from Red Hat's
who was at nothing on so yes he was real
hard first of all but then as Red Hat
became more and more how should we say
had to get more commercially focused
they the happy hobbyist air fell away
from it and you know you have to use
something like fedora I think it wasn't
that was never very happy with that
so the question is then what is my most
recent Linux box well it's an open SUSE
system now before we start getting
avalanches and Mel said why did you
choose that I chose that for the
pragmatic reason that the guys at work
whose judgment I trust had gone for that
flavor of Linux for the whole school of
computer science and I thought well you
know it may not be quite like the Red
Hat I'm used to but if they're offering
backup advice and everything on open
Susie I'll do that at home and it's the
only way to go because it reduces the
hassles
so yes the Box I'm upgrading away from
is openSUSE Linux 13 point to go on Sean
asked me what forced me to upgrade here
we are in a lockdown can't I just wait a
while go on Sean asked me why
well so the there are two main ways that
allows of reasons to upgrade something
but in my estimation there are two main
reasons and there are the two sides of
the one coin of computing hardware or
software where we go in both both
simultaneously and they kind of
interfered with each other to an extent
of giving me inappropriate error
indications what is the software not in
mind but of other people's where they
are determined to obsolete you and get
you to upgrade and sir the web browser
every flaming time I do not watch movies
if you send me an mp3 or mp4 that
standalone that's alright but I am NOT a
mad gamer or I don't watch movies but I
do need to be able to playback my
computer file episodes so there was I
still happily using Firefox from 2014
and somebody without my explicit
permission goes and starts in posing
html5 as a requirement it starts to be
longer and longer and longer before I
could see my version and I think you
told me that because of my ancient setup
I was waiting for a flash version was
that right I do know what Dave I have no
idea I mean YouTube makes dozens and
dozens of versions of each well you know
definitely many many multiples of
different versions from h.264 to blah
blah blah it was making the html5
version first because you were happy I
had to wait for quite some time often
several hours before a version came that
I could view but I couldn't live with
that it was it was getting more and more
annoying I thought this has got to
change but then what tended to happen
was it even on my ancient browser and
even when I wasn't trying to view html5
files of course you get nowhere with
that it was still falling over as we say
a lot that browser and I started
thinking that every time it fell
it was leaving a crash dumper somewhere
because my root disk file system got
full up like crazy and then on top of
that I began to suspect and it took me
back to the mid to late seventies when
this was commonplace that 2014 system is
running off proper conventional discs
right rotating thing is you know with
brown iron oxide on them inside which
our colleague dr. Steve I've never heard
this before calls spinning rust spinning
rust Dave you're on spinning rust I bet
you've got bad blocks I said you're
right we used to get those in the 1970s
off our big dish packs we put in yeah
used to have to do an fsck before you
start it up find your bad blocks map
them out and all that I started to have
the odd file fortunately not important
once at all where I couldn't delete it
it just wouldn't let me because there
were bad blocks so they'll okay for
hardware and software reasons I must now
upgrade so I went to see dr. Steve
without his help I couldn't even begin
to stay in the Linux firmament he said
Dave open Susie is so yesterday and so
deprecated if you want me to support you
and of course this is where we're going
to get in into Linux flavors Wars he
said the flavor of Linux I find just
about tolerable is Debian and I said
Steve whatever you use is fine by me
so long as you can keep me going on that
new version and the first thing he gave
me was a mostly configured Linux system
with no spinning rust I think I've got
16 gig of main memory and something like
200 and something gig of what I still
regard as disc except that it's really
solid state memory now and boy is it a
lot faster than when you having to wait
for the next block to come round on
spinning rust then of course you've got
to ensure that
new Linux system has got all the
utilities on it that the old one had one
of the most wonderful things about Linux
is that you get
I'm sure there's exceptions pretty well
binary compatibility you don't have to
keep on recompiling your stuff
are you listening up there Steve Jobs
one of my problems in doing this upgrade
why I have to have Steve around as a
consultant is that if you start only
doing it every few years you forget
really really crucial things and I mean
one goof look just about finished me was
that in the good old days because disks
was so small you had your root
filesystem
on this disk and you could optionally
have your user file system on physically
separate disk right so you all slash
user and his descendants could be on a
separate disk physical list they're now
all on one walloping great big disk with
lots of partitions but when I was run
out of space on the root filesystem
below that to slash user I saw back in
the Berkley days if you had two smaller
disk you could put slash user on a
separate disk of all right go to super
user mode a little knowledge is a
dangerous thing and I tried moving slash
user through elsewhere to free off more
space and you know what happens next
it won't recognize any or will only
recognize a tiny proportion of your unix
commands when you type them in from a
command line all right
something like who to see who's logged
on doesn't work why because you have
made slash user slash bin where it was
finding the binary to do that you made
it invisible and have forgotten all
about this pick up the fence Steve
actually bless him he was really one
Dave listen carefully
stop gibberish
we'll get it back we've all done it we
have all done this but because after
than you I now do it less frequently and
if I do accidentally do is I know how to
rescue myself so it's things like that
it's a system that back in the seventies
required a lot of expertise oh and
that's another thing look and feel oh no
probably a separate extra bits video on
this that's the one last thing I want to
talk about honestly yeah again you you
go with Steve Jobs you take the pill you
drink the kool-aid or you follow Bill
Gates and his successors and you get
Windows 10 but basically what you see on
your screen is what they think is good
for you you do not get like you do Linux
Oh what sort of windowing system would
you like on top of all this are you a
known customer or are you a KDE customer
well I flirted with both in my time and
I think I've relapsed then they can now
cohabit so I find in this legend steady
they seem to cohabits a lot better but
this is this is the problem of having
such a amorphous market as Linux is
Amman is coming everything from high-end
servers that have all sorts of things so
you can buy in exactly what you want
but-but-but-but it means that if
everything is an add-on then nothing
standard you know so yeah I'm basically
back on a machine that will tolerate
either gnome or KDE but it's choosable
and that suits me fine and yeah even in
the great Wild West that is Linux
systems there are signs of common sense
breaking out I think they are more
upgradable in general perhaps better
maintained than they used to be five or
six years ago it's community it's not a
few computer sizing nerds trying to
rescue
rescue command-line software from the
1980s but yes so I've got all of that
here that sort of thing but the problem
with that is then it becomes very easy
to say